foreign
[Music]
an ancient tradition that it does come
from from people figuring things out and
some of their technology is really
representative of their culture you know
use of Jade use of piercings use of body
modifications
[Music]
thank you
an interesting design challenge because
we were we were delving into characters
that needed rebreathers when they were
above water and trying to create that
look for a series of Warriors that
needed to look Fierce and amazing
being a warrior in that culture is is a
sort of an extreme thing and the idea of
changing your appearance in a way that
would actually allow for you to breathe
you know outside the water becomes a an
important part of who you are as a
person and it almost marks you for life
in some ways
[Music]
we were looking at animals that would
surround them as you know things that
they could possibly Implement as looks
for themselves as Warriors so for
example with with a tomb of the fact
that he's got a hammerhead shark skull
that he wears his sort of helmet or
headdress becomes something that's meant
to be intimidating
the same sort of thing with memory where
we're taking sort of um
oversized lionfish fins and having them
become an amazing headdress for her
it became one of the cooler visuals I
think that our team put out there is
these orcas with 15 20 30 different
teleconneal attached using the the
undersea animals as essentially vehicles
[Music]
the idea of being underwater of
exploring an entire culture that would
have developed and grown and created
itself into something that was a world
power I think is so much fun
[Music]